- Oh, he just wanted to
give us some time alone.
NARRATOR: Anne Heche first
rose to Fame on the soap opera,
"Another World",
playing the dual roles
of twins, Vicky Hudson and
Marley Love from 1987 to 1991.
It earned her a
Daytime Emmy award
and led to films like "Donnie
Brasco", "Six Days, Seven
Nights", and "Wag the Dog".
But it was her highly
publicized romantic relationship
with Ellen DeGeneres in
the late 90s that really
put her in the spotlight.
- Ellen is to me the embodiment
of both male and female.
I think that's why our energies
connected so quickly and so
easily, because I've
always felt in my being
that I'm both male and female.
NARRATOR: They were
considered one of Hollywood's
first lesbian power
couples before breaking
up after 3 and 1/2 years.
Heche said that she believed
it damaged her career
and cost her roles.
- This is impossible.
NARRATOR: Heche eventually
bounced back though,
in both her career
and personal life.
She appeared in
numerous TV shows
and was married for eight
years to Coleman Laffoon.
They had a son.
She also shared a son with
her former "Men in Trees"
co-star, James Tupper.
- Even though I was
in therapy for years,
I never told anybody that
I had another personality,
I never told anybody that I
heard voices and spoke to God,
I never told anybody any of it.
NARRATOR: The actress was
open about her battles
with mental illness.
In her 2001 memoir,
"Call Me Crazy",
she wrote about enduring
sexual abuse as a child.
Heche was hospitalized
in 2000 after wandering
in rural California knocking
on a stranger's door
and making strange statements.
- I think I was at the
bitter, bitter end.
I was in a place where
I was ready to leave
this planet on my spaceship.
NARRATOR: A fiery 2022 car
crash put her in a coma
and left her with severe burns.
Anne Heche led a life of
public highs and lows.
But through it all,
she shined on screen
and strived to stay hopeful.
- I've always wanted
to heal my life,
I've always wanted to see
the good side of life,
the good in everything
that happened to me.
And I could not be happier
with who I am right now.
I couldn't be happier
with what I've been
able to accomplish in my life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]